certainly tom's
you know a
iconic figure in this organization and
nobody respects tom more than i do but i
respect all the other players and all
the other coaches in this organization
too and so
you know i think that everybody that is
part of it
[Music]
is an important part of it and i want to
you know give the proper attention and
communication and detail and
thought into
my input into those decisions but any
decisions made is
you know
it's not an individual decision it's
there are other people involved so there
has to be some type of
communication understanding
agreement whatever you want to call it
and that's not a one-way street i hope
you can understand that it's one person
just can't decide what everybody else is
going to do
when players are under contract and we
have a lot of players that aren't under
contract
that's what it sounds like when a guy
who is used to being in control of
everything
has
no control over tom brady for 2020.
that's the kind of meandering that you
get chris because the bottom line is it
doesn't matter what bill belichick wants
yeah that doesn't mean a thing right the
first question in this analysis for the
new england patriots is what does tom
brady want because they could want him
back desperately and if he wants to go
somewhere else he's going somewhere else
right or the vice versa if they don't
want them back and mr craft and tom want
to come back he's going to be back right
i mean i think that could go either way
so yeah bill can only state his case at
this point to ownership and it's this is
a huge huge whoa whoa whoa
would bill belichick
would he stand for having tom brady cram
down his throat and would brady want to
continue to stay if it's obvious
belichick doesn't want i i don't know
you're right i mean i don't know that
i'm not sure
um but you know again i think it's
another player where you're your point
it's just like i'm not sure
bill has total jurisdiction over this
one player in this one conversation you
know this is a true organizational
conversation and the kraft family will
certainly be involved go ahead what
you know what the ultimate power play
would be from tom brady what it's the
magic johnson power play
i'll i'll run the coach off and i'll
bring in my own guy that's the ultimate
power play here yeah well that would be
stupid if the crafts
because i'm just saying if we're talking
if we're talking about you know
shakespeare shakespearean drama type
stuff right high level you know uh cloak
and dagger who's really in control right
uh i
that would be the ultimate move if br if
he if he truly is the unofficial son of
robert kraft he could pull it off if he
wanted to well he could probably
certainly put some pressure on that
situation there's no doubt uh but i
still think you know bill belichick is
mostly king of that jurisdiction still
but you know hey this is the big
question with the new england patriots
obviously hey listen we know they need
more weapons and they could use another
big time receiver if not two of them get
it yes maybe you know they need some
improvement to their offensive line
there were some guys there that really
underperformed this year they paid shaq
mason he played like crap you know
marcus cannon at right tackle had issues
but the big thing is before you sort
anything out is brady and i think you
know hey brady's play down the stretch
it was average it was average at best
i'm being that's all there is to it and
i know people think i'm the brady hater
at some times i'm just being honest okay
so the play was average and it's the
first time in tom brady's career that i
can look back at a year and go really
tom brady won them no games this year i
mean they won games because of their
defense and he took care of the football
there was other years where i've gone
man brady was so awesome he carried the
team he won them like legitimately four
or five games but this year that did not
happen and uh this is the big question
not only for the whole nfl but to the
patriots is what to do here because
they're they're not far off i mean the
patriots a weapon on offense another big
guy or two on the defensive line and the
patriots are back to being in the
conversation as the best team in
football
yeah i don't know how crazy this thought
is but you just have to wonder how
patriots fans would react to
bill belichick plus some quarterback
other than tom brady versus
tom brady and josh mcdaniels and bill
belichick is
uh is out
how how do you think the average
patriots fan would react to that choice
which of the two would they i think the
patriots fans are extremely intelligent
and they realize that i think they would
sacrifice one more year of okay we don't
have brady and it's over for belichick
for five or six more years and knowing
that there's a chance that still
greatness could come out of that i think
the patriot fans are smart enough to
know that at this point so also because
bill would take steve with him and
they're starting to well since that's
the
check is going to be the next in line
and continue this belichick patriots
connection for decades well it does seem
like there is something that and there's
you know there's there there is there's
the rumor you know in the nfl that i've
always heard that like you know hey bill
belichick did mr kraft a favor by
shipping jimmy garoppolo out to san
francisco and that maybe this would be
the favor in return would to be steve
belichick the guy in waiting when bill
does leave so just throwing that out
there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports